dans ce service d'endoscopie digestive
de l'hôpital trousseau
on pratique chaque année plus de 6000
gastroscopie et coloscopie l'examen est
pratiqué dans le côlon ou l'estomac
grâce à un endoscope spécifique une
sorte de tube flexible pourvu d'une
fibre optique est relié à une caméra
après un examen non de ce cap est amené
dans cette salle pour y être nettoyés et
totalement désinfecter d'abord était si
un premier nettoyage est un massage dans
paillasse médina manuellement et ensuite
on met les endoscopes wendel 2e c'est à
dire des laveurs désinfecteurs pour
endoscope dans ce service depuis
l'existence d'un tel mode de
décontamination aucune infection
nosocomiale a été transmise à un patient
à la suite d'utilisation d'un endoscope
depuis quelques années on a émaux
énormément amélioré notre efficacité
notre hygiène nos procédures
notre traçabilité comme je disais est ce
qui nous a beaucoup aidé c'est de
collaborer avec le service d'hygiène
en plus du nettoyage les appareils sont
tracées grâce à un code barre on sait
qu'elle endoscope a été utilisé à quel
moment
sur quels patients et quelle personne la
nettoyer pour le docteur godard gastro
entérologue le risque d'infection de
skopies qui est aujourd'hui négligeable
dans un service d'endoscopie digestive
les risques infectieux sont je veux dire
quasiment nul aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
rides infections nosocomiales comme on
peut l'entendre
pour moi le principal risque qu'on fait
une coloscopie notamment sais c'est pas
l'infection c'est le risque de
perforation le colon sein d'un organe
qui est fragile et quand passe une
caméra rigide c'est ça le risque
aujourd'hui même si le risque de
perforation existe l'écart est
exceptionnelle de l'ordre de 1 sur 10000
l'endoscopie aujourd'hui l'examen de
référence pour le dépistage des maladies
inflammatoires du côlon et des cancers
digestifs